This episode was proudly made possible by
the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
It's not just a sedan, it's a Subaru.
Can you see everything on the screen without
moving your eyes?
Look at me did you see that?
Didn't think so.[a]
Howdy lookers, thanks for tuning into DNews,
I'm Trace.
Eyes are little 1 inch diameter balls (2.54
cm) tucked in your head, and though they're
magnificent, human eyes aren't even CLOSE
to the best in the animal kingdom.
In fact, your brain is tricking you into thinking
your eye is seeing things that aren't there
RIGHT NOW.
We've all got blind spots that we can't see,
and huge sections of our vision are just…
wrong!
Take a piece of paper with a dot and a plus
on it.
Close one eye, hold the paper close to your
face and look straight at the dot, pulling
it away slowly.
Eventually, the plus should disappear!
That's your blind spot.
If you switch eyes, the dot should disappear.
You might have to try it a couple of times.
To understand WHY this happens, we have to
go inside the eye.
If you could fly into the pupil and inside
the eyeball to look around you'd be floating
in vitreous humor of the inner eye.
It's a clear, gel-like material.
On the walls of the eye, you'd see blood vessels
streaming everywhere, and spread across the
back of the eye you'd see the rod and cone
cells of the retina.
Rods are for low light, cones are for color
and visual detail.
If you got closer to the retina, you could
spot the macula right in the middle with only
cone cells -- that's the only part of your
vision that you can see clearly.
If you look at my face here, you can see it
clearly, but while still looking at my face
pay attention to the walls around me, or my
shirt.
It's VERY difficult to comprehend the rest
of your visual field.
The macula is truly the only point of visual
clarity!
From there, you could follow the nerves of
the retina, like following a bunch of extension
cords to the wall.
Eventually, you'd get to the optic disk; a
part of the eye with no rods or cones.
That's where the optic nerve enters the eyeball!
It's kind of like where your eye plugs in.
And it causes a blind spot.
There's nothing there for your eye to perceive
since there are no rod or cone cells!
My eye doctor was nice enough to send me a
picture of the inside of my own eye.
You can see the macula here, and the optic
nerve here.
That is my point of clarity, and my blind
spot!
If it seems stupid to have a blind spot, you're
right.
Cephalapods don't have one, because their
optic nerves run BEHIND the retina rather
than in front of it.
Think of it this way, cephalopods have their
wiring inside the walls, but because of an
unfortunate evolutionary mutation, mammals
didn't and thus we all have blind spots.
The reason you don't see this spot all the
time is because your brain fills it in.
Try doing the dot and plus experiment with
a piece of colorful paper and your brain will
fill it in with color.
That's your brain tricking you into thinking
your vision is perfect, when it's really not.
Silly brain, tricks are for non-scientists.
Blind spots are very important to be aware
of - especially when you’re driving!
That’s why we wanna thank Subaru for making
this episode possible.
And especially the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
Every sedan has its benefits, but only one
combines them all.
It’s not just a sedan.
It’s a Subaru.
If you could have the eyes of another animal,
which would it be?
Cats?
Eagles?
Cephalopods?
Mantis Shrimp?!
We're watching for your comments, so leave
one.
Thanks for watching DNews.
Here's looking at you, kid.
Please subscribe.